[Music]
i've followed counter-strike for a long
long time all iterations of it i have
rarely seen
a player with the raw talent and raw
ability of
simple nitro does have a lot of another
smoke so it could be really rough or
simple to actually get through this he's
gonna throw the awp oh my god
simple war is happening what even is
that
the most annoying thing was
when he was toxic
[Music]
there were a lot of times when elysian
simple would
get into disagreements simple would
really really get an allegiance face
about it just yet
it may catch bialy off does with an
eagle she does have armor if you could
just grab an ak
okay that's enough he's got two one taps
he's feeling it selecting the same with
the pistol
simple he's up to the third and the ak
pulled out oh my god simple
four kills so maybe the actual the
answer is actually the problem is simple
not the team in the same place they're
simple just jumping casually to the side
he's gonna fall down again
simple why are you serious what is that
you can't do that simple
that's not allowed this is not mpl this
is a major
alexander simple castelliev
started playing counter-strike at the
age of four
under the supervision of his brother
alexei while growing up
in ukraine alexei would handle the
keyboard
and simple would be responsible for the
mouse
as simple grew older the two brothers
would constantly fight
over the household's only computer oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
simple was only 15 when counter-strike
global offensive
released in 2012. and a year later he'd
make his semi-pro debut
with a ukrainian team called the land
dodgers
primarily as a rifler simple joined
courage gaming
in early 2014 and started to gain a
reputation around europe
for being an up-and-coming talent
shortly after star series
simple left courage due to internal
issues and rejoined the dodgers
who later rebranded as amazing gaming
it was at this time that simple first
picked up the op
simple got his big break midway through
2014
as a 17 year old when he joined the
likes of markaloff and dosia
on hellraisers the team had seen his
performance at star series and taken
notice
of his undeniable talent missing an
opportunity for almost getting a double
frank they're gonna chase him down
simple we'll pick up the kill anyway
against the second one hellraiser's most
notable achievement with simple
came during the group stage of dreamhack
winter 2014.
there simple and co defeated the best
team in the world
fanatic and simple now bringing the off
the bear
hell race is picking fnatic apart
finally there's a reply but it's not
enough hell races
they take first seat in the group oh for
the favorites fanatic
16-14 victory on mirage what a game
while the win was big the team
ultimately bowed out in the quarters
where they lost to ninjas in pajamas
early on in his professional career
simple was characterized as a young
prodigy
a generational talent who showed signs
of brilliance
and still had a lot of room to learn and
grow
i've followed counter-strike for a long
long time all iterations of it i have
rarely seen a player with the raw talent
and roar ability
of simple simple's climb up the ranks of
eu cs go was steady up until that
dreamhack event
but just a few months later he was
abruptly banned from esl
and was forced to part ways with
hellraisers
while he was banned simple signed on
with the almost entirely ukrainian
flipside tactics the team made a
commitment to simple that hellraisers
wouldn't
and agreed to find stand-ins for him at
esl events
he stayed with flipside until july 2015
when his relationship with the team
ended again because of
internal issues a sign of things to come
for simple about simple i can say that
the most annoying thing was
when he was toxic you could see that he
was
really toxic during the game and he was
trying to
to infuriate you markloff would later
elaborate on
what caused the break markolov said
simple was
always yelling and arguing and too
critical of his teammates
damaging their team chemistry markolov
thought that the loss was not as big as
the community was making it out to be
it was here that the simple effect was
born
foreshadowing the next two years of his
career
but amidst the breakup even markloff
admitted that simple had
god-like aim and incredible in-game
confidence
that's enough he's feeling it this was
starting to be simple's reputation
around the cs go community
his talent was undeniable he played with
more confidence than
almost any young player the game had
ever
seen and he executed plays that were
simply
unbelievable looking for the ace now and
he will find me a simple it will just
simply kill everyone the fia needs to
implement balance of performance because
that is ridiculous give this man a
handicap
he played with the same arrogance his
teammates always associated
with his personality and it lit up the
scoreboard
simple you monster oh simple
oh good god oh my god simple
after leaving flipside simple's career
went through a sporadic few months
that saw him bounce in and out of
different lineups
in july 2015 he announced he'd be taking
a break from cs go
to focus on finishing university but
then just a few weeks later
joined evolution dark he then spent some
time standing in for hellraisers after
dosia abruptly left
as well as for flipside while standing
in with flipside
simple formed a strong bond with
longtime north american pro
heco which would pave the way for his
future career decisions
he has full faith in me to make the
right play
and get my kills i don't think he's
really had that in another teammate ever
in his career probably he knows almost
no matter what
you know he can say anything he wants to
me and i'm not going to be mad at him
and i'm not going to hate him for it
on january 2nd 2016 simple signed with
one of north america's
largest esports organizations team
liquid
he was 18 years old and he decided to
put his education on hold
and leave europe to chase a major title
just a month after joining liquid
simple's esl
ban expired surrounded by a strong team
and big
org the world was ready to see just how
good
simple was i don't want to say he's like
the michael jordan of cs go but he has
like the same superstar mentality where
he expects everyone to show up on time
he expects everyone to show up
at their you know best performance he
wants to win every practice like 16-0
you know he holds himself to a high
center he holds everyone else the same
center
that he holds himself to and this was
where his relationship with hiko
would come into play hiko was arguably
one of na's best talents at the time
and liquid had a roster to be reckoned
with
it didn't take long for liquid to find
success
to the major what's it going to be here
10 seconds
heco gets the bomb down mosquito take
one of them out on the cross no not
going to go for it oh
he looks up to the window he go gets the
head shot and advances
another team to the mlg major
with the management of liquid helping
out and with james and with myself
really trying to to work on making sure
he stays focused and he stays
at a level head i think he's getting
better outside the game he's he's great
you know i think he's really funny
i get along with him really well they
made it to the semi-finals at mlg major
championship
columbus 2016 just a few months later
he's double scoped in down goes first
with the awp but eco turns around
grabs fnx shuts him down now it's taco
up there and simple's got the angle
see you later taco just cold now left
standing for the brazilian side
to get a simple up with that angle oh
looks like actually
and nitrous gonna get the kill off the
time that's a big win for liquid
simple was named to the all-star game at
that event and was also named
the all-star mvp
[Music]
liquid would then carry that momentum
into the next major esl one cologne 2016
but with one catch it would be simple's
last time
playing with team liquid simple has is
probably
one of the best teammates i've ever had
as far as individually skill goes
i don't think there's a better player
maybe in the game that has as much skill
as simple does
it's going to be sad seeing him go
shortly before that event simple went
back home to ukraine
and abruptly decided that he would not
be returning to north america
to play for liquid luckily for tl
he did end up playing as a stand-in at
cologne
liquid lost in the grand final to sk
gaming beating fnatic in the semis
at the time it was the best performance
ever for an
n a team at a cs go major but just
as soon as liquid realized how good they
could be was simple on their roster
their ukrainian star was gone
simple did leave liquid with a parting
gift in the form of one of his most
famous plays
the falling off and the desperate play
in 2b comes in
smokes let's get double smokes in the
same place there simple just jumping
casually into the side
he's going to fall down again from
simple are you serious
what is that you can't do that simple
that's not allowed this is not mpl
this is a major james simple is an
assassin this guy
is absolutely unbelievable he's the ex
factor for team liquid there is no
question
simple had everything he'd ever asked
for
one of the best n a talents in hiko two
solid riflers and a quality offer in jdm
he accomplished what he set out to do he
surrounded himself
with talent and then carried his team to
the top
of the counter-strike world and then he
turned around
and went home it was very hard to play
in liquid in another i mean another
city without parents without friends for
me it's very comfortable
to be in the home after cologne
news about simple's relationship with
team liquid took the cs go community
by storm as time went on he saw
adren maybe not as focused as he would
have liked
missing easy shots that in simple's mind
simple would never miss so
there were a couple times when we wanted
to quit the team he
didn't want to play it simple at all he
tried a couple of times to say you know
hey if simple's on the team i don't want
to play anymore
just like with flipside and hellraisers
before them
the simple effect had plagued liquid
at this point simple's reputation as a
toxic teammate was common knowledge
but his reputation as one of the best
players on the planet
was equally ubiquitous the move to
liquid was certainly daunting
but in game simple handled it without a
hiccup
he took a typical n a team and made them
a contender
with two major top four appearances
simple gave
n a results they'd never seen before he
was truly one of the best
on the planet even without a major title
many in the community were placing his
raw talent
and confident gameplay above the likes
of nico
olofmeister and coldzera the gods
of cs go then in august of 2016
simple replaced zeus on natas vincere
his hometown team
with an almost entirely ukrainian roster
it seemed
like a perfect match before he left
zeus was the team's primary player shot
caller
but they largely relied on their coach
starrix
to lead at the time so zeus was a
natural cut
there was some concern about the
acquisition though flamey and seized
were known for issues with their
temperament
just like simple and many were worried
about how these extreme personalities
would mesh but just a month after the
acquisition
valve made major changes to the rules
regarding in-game shot calling
coaches were no longer able to
communicate with players on comms
during games to shock call for them
because of this
starix navi's coach was removed from his
role
and was unable to call games for the
team
with star x out and zeus gone there was
no one left
to wrangle the team's brightest stars
simple
and guardian in his first premier event
with na'vi
simple and his new teammates won esl one
new york emphatically making their
presence felt
as a force in the eu scene during that
event
simple was plus 54 with
kills over nine maps and was named mvp
of the entire tournament
simple would then be named the red bull
esports 2016 player of the year
and managed to avoid controversy with
na'vi
as the 2017 season was about to start
simple had his eyes set on that elusive
major title
i want to win every tournament in the
world i want to help create new era
of nato spencer navi came up short at
the e-league major in atlanta
finishing in the top eight that
performance was followed up with a top
16 finish at pgl krakow simple was still
playing like a superstar
but just like all of his previous teams
navi had become
the simple show there is just a little
edge of something different about simple
that makes you think
i actually believe this guy can do
anything in the game let's have a look
at another smoke so it could be really
rough or simple to actually get through
this he's going to throw the awp in oh
my god
simple what is happening
what even is that he was without a doubt
carrying the ukrainian squad and the
internal issues that had plagued his
past
were rearing their ugly face once again
the team previously played around
guardians off playing slow
and allowing him to secure picks now
with simple's hyper-aggressive play
style
guardian was trying to fit into their
new system and with star x gone
navi was spiraling getting the kill on c
is not much left now simple gets another
one but he's trapped in the corner he's
gonna go down and fnatic will make their
way through
16-12 against navi knocking them out of
the tournament
what a team and what a story we were
definitely doubting them and they showed
us that was a big mistake
and while you can tell the
disappointment a lot of shining eyes
over there on na'vi's side
and well they got so far in cologne as
well and you could tell that they were
shattered at their loss there and to not
make it out of the groups here at the
major
this is a disaster for na'vi shortly
after krakow both seized and guardian
were
placed on the transfer wire guardian
left the team for faze clan in july
and seized would eventually step down
from the starting lineup
in october after crackout navi started
to slump
they had a string of consistently
mediocre results
and were no longer thought of as a major
contender
despite stellar numbers 2017 was a
pretty disappointing year
for simple in terms of results prior to
the e-league boston major at the start
of 2018
navi added another young phenom in
electronic
the team made it all the way to the top
four with their electronic empowered
lineup
a stellar performance from flamey and
simple
doing what he does best
since then simple has managed to avoid
bad press
navi has been inconsistent but still
impressive
and seems to be getting along they
recently played mousesports in the
finals of starladder
and simple once again showed the world
how good
he is good crossfire potentially isolate
this into one-on-ones rather than
getting caught
see the plant goes back out those rops
is peeking and nails the shot as well
against these eggs ladies and gentlemen
do not try this at home
it's a horrible idea to repeat and it's
down to something
but never discount simple the flames
hits it gets away as well as the smoke
dissolves because he was susceptible
and vulnerable towards the sandwich
simple stepping up that was a miss sonny
was just far off in the wide peak he's
got position
how does he hit that how is he that no
he's still in the animation of jumping
and somehow nails the shot on sunny
simple who turns 21 this year had 90
kills in three games during the finals
sporting a plus 37 plus minus rating
he carried navi when they were down and
showed up big when they had the momentum
it's starting to feel like simple may
have finally settled into a team
but we'll have to wait and see if na'vi
will end up surviving
the simple effect i learned a lot i
learned that
you shouldn't be angry on your team have
a lot of respect for your teammates
i learned how to be always calm calm you
know
because i know for myself if i'm so
emotional in game i'm going to play very
bad
and we're going to lose i learn it after
i lose a lot of tournaments
there is no question that simple is one
of the most uniquely talented players
in the history of cs go but
in exchange for stunning off-picks and
clutch after clutch
you get simple behind the scenes
combative
destructive and unpredictable
the upper echelon of the cs world is
currently dominated
by players that have bought in to a team
first
system powerhouses like sk gaming and
faze clan
have assembled star-studded rosters that
aren't afraid to play for their
teammates
instead of their stat line will simple
find his balance with na'vi
or will he be relegated to a pile of
talent impressive but
ultimately wasted left without results
is the simple effect a blessing or a
curse
only time will tell
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button